caro babbo natale quest'anno ti chiedo
tantissimi vegas natale prima verso 2020
iscriviti al canale per non perdere
neanche un video delle bambole e
castella sette piani la bicicletta il
gup a cio che ho visto ieri in vetrina
il monopattino l'iphone nevada
televisivi il cambio di un canone vero
caro babbo natale quest'anno per la
prima volta forse ti chiedo veramente
poche cose ma sono molto importanti fai
sparire questo benedetto coronavirus non
se ne può più
e poi io voglio tornare alla mia
normalità allora vedere le mie amiche e
andare a ballare insomma hai capito e
seconda cosa il mio fidanzato in zona
rossa da jabri queste benedette regioni
io ho bisogno di vederlo mi manca
tantissimo non ce la faccio più a fare
videochiamate una the white il 4 5 6
giorni a natale chiari giorni è natale
tecnici natale iamm natalizi 17
diciassette giorni alla fine dell'anno
ma questo 2020 lo finisce per 1 0 e poi
17 forse un segno e non l'ho più
sfortunato del mondo magari vuol dire
che anche prossimo anno sarà spiegato io
giuro
vado a vivere su marte e basta è allora
a mamma compro e vestito che le piace a
marika i trucchi che voleva a tommy come
da tradizione regalerò in maglione di
natale alla piccola peste quest'anno
regaliamo il monopattino e ai nonni un
super weekend alle terme che natale
banale alla mamma al posto dei suoi
rivestiti ne regalerò bigiano no perché
tanto cosa li regalare city a fare se
non può uscire dalla piccola peste che
voleva tanto il monopattino il mio
regalo a fare per usarlo in balcone no
volevo regalare uno stupendo weekend
relax alle terme
a sto punto posso prendere la poltrona
relax quella automatica che al 6 pieri
che eni cuginetta ecco il tuo regalo se
quello che volevo io credo
ecco il regalo di natale grazie mari
avvicinati paura e guarda che ho appena
fatto siro logico tutta possa e io ho
fatto il tampone filati è l'unico a
rilevare il virus e poi a dirla tutta tu
sei venuta da una zona rossa ma non ha
veramente e zona gialla da due giorni e
comunque autocertificazione come scusami
cosa è scritto nell'auto certificazione
solo per motivi lavorativi ma no che
sono dovuta passare da fare con la mia
famiglia il mio nucleo familiare
famiglia siamo cugini di secondo grado è
ai i denti pensiamo a cena con tutta la
compagnia ho evitato ivan alessia luca
tutti quanti il 24 cellule dai miei con
supercar o che patty non vedo l'ora
il 25 a pranzo dai tuoi e 25 sera come
al solito cinema di rito con zio toni
che i cucinieri un'intesa finalmente
partiamo per la montagna
e allora inizieranno le nostre vedere
vacanze di natale
sciate passeggiate branzi in baita e
relax nella nostra spa preferita amore
una notizia per te sarà un natale di
merda ma come perché anche se il suo a
festeggiare il natale che non si può
fare nulla
vorrei tantissimo passare già il primo
gennaio simo morbo che senso ha c'è il
carattere e senza i cenoni con gli amici
senza le discoteche al 23 sera senza
caro che partì dai miei il 24 un amore è
il pranzo del 25 coi tuoi è l'unica cosa
che non mi mancherà
per non parlare della nostra settimane
montagna quello che ci facevano sempre
che senso ha tanto hanno chiuso tutte le
piste non si può sciare mai sentito da
luisa porta la lasagna fabio martina
porteranno il vino io porto il pandoro
allo spumante inzio calogero la cassata
top di a rosi pasticcini luca gli
antipasti sino a ma tranquilla per
domani tutto pronto mi ha fatto il
tampone bortolotto certificazione zia
rosi non viene perché diventano rossano
si può spostare fabio martina verranno
ma tanto erano dalla finestra al massimo
faranno brindisi rigorosamente a
distanza zio calogero non viene perché
in isolamento e luca porto a 15
mascherine sp2
non ho capito perché ne porta 15
serafina fare mentre
[Musica]